from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find all the differences
between McDonald's in the US and
Australia this is food
Wars before we get started I wanted to
introduce our new host Brit she is going
to be our food Wars expert down in
Australia and I hope you guys love her
as much as I do she is
lovely in the US our fries come in four
sizes kids small medium and large in
Australia Al fries come in three
different sizes is small medium and
large let's weigh our largest
fry I am so impressed by this stack by
the way this is a master paste
wow get a load of that stack of fries
very impressive that's it for me bye
what about the iconic Big Mac let's
weigh
it some of our Burger options come in
different sizes to the us we have a
single cheeseburger a double
cheeseburger and and a triple
cheeseburger over here the standard
McDonald's cheeseburger only comes in
two sizes the single or the double our
McDonald's drinks come in four sizes
extra small which we could not get small
medium and large our drinks in Australia
come in three sizes small medium and
large 12 flu o is the size of a can of
Coke so it's so wild to me that that is
the smallest size of Beverage you could
get at McDonald's let's measure our
largest string our largest string came
out to 800 ml when we're supposed to be
getting
946 that is a grous that's so so unfair
it's not even 600 it's not even 600 but
but what number is it so our large is
coming at 520 M 650 to 520 is a massive
difference daylight rubbery chicken
nuggets in the US come in five sizes a
four piece a six- piece a 10piece a 20
piece and a 40 piece our chicken nuggets
come in five sizes we have a three piece
a six Pace a 10 Pace a 20 pace and a 40
Pace finally another country matches us
with the 40 piece it's only taken us two
years of food Wars to find
one here is everything at an Australian
McDonald's you won't find in the US
here's everything at a US McDonald's you
won't find in Australia there are a lot
of things over here that you can't find
in the states like these socks we're
going to break them down into categories
and go through them all I really need to
try these socks on because they are
amazing look at that fashion fun I'm
going to feel like a criminal with these
bad boys
Hamburglar starting with the beef
burgers we have a classic Angus a
barbecue bacon Angus a spicy sticky
barbecue Angus we have a triple
cheeseburger big Brey Burger which I
just couldn't resist and I really needed
to try that and then we have a mcfist
and then we finish off with the double
Big Mac it's
massive I think you taste more meat than
the actual like sauce with the
combination of the meat I think just a
regular Big Mac is probably better cuz
you get more flavor so if you look at
these burgers that we have here this
Angus looks at little bit more premium
than the others I definitely think
there's a culture in Australia that
really enjoys high quality beef high
quality Burgers which is why these Drew
so well here here are the exclusive
Burger options we have a McDouble my
favorite and then we have two quar
Pounders with cheese one just has bacon
on it I think what makes it different
than a double cheese burger is that the
double cheeseburger has two slices of
cheese and no ketchup confir irm or deny
that right here for me the McDouble also
has thinner patties which I prefer to
the thicker ones moving on I do want to
try one of the Quarter Pounders I'm
going for the one with bacon in it
because obviously this looks like a
perfect little Burger you could be in
commercials not good so this is the
quarter pounder Deluxe with cheese next
let's take a look at our chicken and
fish options we have over here first and
starting strong we we have a deluxe
chicken it's a grilled chicken with
lettuce tomato Mayo it's aoli and moving
on we have our mixed spicy smells
peppery it's got a bit of a kick but I
wouldn't say that it's oh oh it's the
after kick it gets spicy oh my gosh it's
creaming up on me I actually really like
this next one is the double McChicken
this is a heavy Burger two pie pieces of
chicken on
it you're not missing out on this in
europea thumbs down m- while we're
talking about chicken we have a bunch of
chicken wraps here in Australia starting
with the Caesar grilled chicken mrap we
have a Caesar crispy chicken mrap we
have an aoli grilled chicken mrap
another aoli crispy chicken mrap and
then we have a grilled chicken Snack
Wrap and we were supposed to have a
whole meal but there's no whole meal
wraps available let's try the aoli
grilled chicken
mrap that's really good it's really
light I wouldn't mind having a look at
the crispy chicken Caesar wrap the
chicken inside as well look really good
it's tearing me
down it's better than the other one the
Yoli chicken bur a flavor in your mouth
moving on to our chicken options we have
the spicy MC Krispy the spicy M Krispy
Deluxe and the Reg regular MC Krispy
Deluxe I think that Deluxe in McDonald's
terminology just means it has lettuce
and tomato on it so this is the spicy MC
Krispy that is really good and it's
actually so spicy and finally we have
the following salad options classic
chicken salad and then we also have a
Caesar salad and we have a garden salad
that looks really sad it's quite tragic
actually little seasoning for this SE is
a salad I don't really care about a
salad McDonald's us used to serve salads
but they started disappearing from menus
during the pandemic and have not
reemerged I for one do not miss them I'm
not going to McDonald's for a salad if I
wanted a salad I'd just go to a salad
place you know Australians can of course
enjoy McDonald's iconic Happy Meals
including some things you won't find in
America the grilled chicken Snack rat
grape tomatoes a pop top which is an
apple juice equivalent imagine if you
were a kid and you let Mom take me to
macers and you drove past and she gave
you this I like the healthy option but
you'd be absolutely devastated that is
punishment that is awful and a little
toy spot it classic spot what exactly
it's just like P what is this this is
too complicated for me how would this
this is really boring I would hate this
if I was a kid no give me a Tamagotchi
or something I don't know what to give
kids like kids in the US are limited to
just a hamburger or nuggets plus fries
and apple slices one thing I thought was
interesting is that you can't get a soda
with the Happy Meal anymore they only
really give you juice options or milk
which is what I have here our Happy Meal
theme is Crash Bandicoot which I haven't
seen since I was a child I think I had
this game on like Nintendo 64 it's it's
very old but I think it's like a new
mobile game collaboration that they're
doing doing I do want to see what my toy
is Spyro's memory card game it's took
memory card game that's not that good I
feel like the toys have really gone
downhill since I was a kid we used to
get stuff like good
stuff wait is this a card game or
no what oh my God it's like a little oh
it's a tin the cards are in the tin
that's actually kind of
cute this is not going to satisfy the
iPad kids they're going to put this in
the garbage so here's our little card
game it is kind of cute that they made
the Box a little Crash Bandicoot crate
that's fun that's the Happy Meal in the
US here are the exclusive sides from
mackers we have some McDonald Land
cookies and a pettin yum strawberry
yogurt we do also have the mozzarella
sticks with chili jam however they were
out of stock of that
today oh my gosh this smell reminds me
of my childhood can I pull this I'm
going to pull this you've got Ronald
McDonald's dark with glasses on I'm sure
that's
someone they're hard cookies but
generally in Australia our cookies are
generally quite hard I don't know why
but they're delicious we actually don't
have any sides in the US that you can't
also find in Australia the one thing I
wish that we had that Australia has is
those mozzarella sticks I would devour
some mozzarella sticks right now is that
time it's sauce talk sace talk we
actually don't have very many sauces to
talk about I have Ranch plain mustard
and we're missing a regular packet of
honey I'm not really sure why they have
honey as a sauce option like what do you
use that for I guess you could use it on
the biscuits I know what Ranch tastes
like I know what mustard tastes like we
don't have to talk about it anymore
sauce talk is over here are the Aussie
exclusive sauces we have a wasabi
flavored Mayo a truffle flavored Mayo a
aoli sauuce and sweet mustard all right
let's try it so this is the
aoli Yum qu garlicky as well so this is
this sweet
mustard it's just not good meat but yeah
ioli is like a classic here anything
with garlic anything with like a really
strong flavor that makes people want to
stay far away from you when you speak
and breathe we on twip if you actually
manage to wake up in time for breakfast
then you'll find a ton of exclusive
breakfast items here in the US
McDonald's actually did do an all day
breakfast menu which was revolutionary
lives were changed and then in March of
2020 they stopped and we went back to
breakfast until 11: 11 doesn't sound
like that early of a time but for me
yeah it
is and in the US you can obviously get
your breakfast sandwich on a variety of
vessels like the biscuit we also have
the MCG griddle which is essentially two
little pancakes with a bunch of syrup
holes so the syrup is already
incorporated into the pancake bun and
whoever thought of this as a sandwich
something special happened something
shifted because this is one of the
greatest things I've ever seen and
tasted we don't have that here but I
can't say I'm particularly jealous the
idea of having syrupy pancakes as like a
bun with meat is just a bit weird
however I know that you guys rave on
about it so I'd be really really
inclined to try it because I want to
know how it would actually taste there's
also the McMuffin which is an English
muffin there's also a variety of
different proteins that you can get in
your breakfast sandwich like I'm seeing
ham bacon sausage and now steak which
was a shock to me would I didn't hear
anything about McDonald's adding steak
to its breakfast menu but we got it
let's start with this steak
biscuit in my brain when I saw the steak
on the menu I was like wow they're doing
like little bits of steak that's
actually so impressive this is a burger
patty in a breakfast sandwich form it
doesn't taste bad this is my favorite
MCG griddle it's the bacon egg and
cheese all those little dark spots those
are the syrup hes these are always going
to hit for me they're good this is the
McMuffin with Canadian bacon cheese and
egg the egg on this one is a little
different than the rest it's supposed to
be a freshly Cracked
Egg I wasn't in the room when this was
made so I can't speak on that but it
looks different than the folded egg
obviously that was a little tough and
lastly we have the sausage
burrito that's pretty good I'm not going
to lie moving on to the breakfast meals
these are like bigger portions there's
more stuff involved it's not just a
quick little sandwich we have the big
breakfast there's the big breakfast with
hot cakes which comes with all of that
stuff plus some hot cakes there's the
hot cakes with a sausage patty and all
the hot cake meals come with whipped
butter and syrup duh the hotcakes at
McDonald's are a
little they taste kind of fake like they
don't taste like real pancakes but I'm a
big fan of them I don't know there's
something very nostalgic about the hot
cakes for me we also have the fruit and
maple oatmeal which comes with fruit and
I am assuming Maple already incorporated
into the oatmeal let's pour these
in okay this actually smells really good
am I just
hungry it's a good oatmeal I would order
that again doesn't taste too sweet and
the parts that are sweet are fruit so I
don't really feel bad eating it we only
have a couple of exclusive breakfast
bites here in Australia we have the miny
McMuffin or the big Brey burger if you
can see two patties onion and a hash
brown cheese egg I don't think my mouth
is going to open up like wi
enough all right I'm I'm slightly
intimidated that is so good unreal I
recommend that so now we have the mighty
McMuffin s of regular McMuffin it's
better than
that it's not as flavorful as this this
is a subtle explosion not a full
earthquake this is I that look like I
actually really like it so here we have
all of our M Cafe exclusive drinks first
up we have the iced french vanilla latte
which sounds very
good it's sweet that is very sweet
they're giving Duncan a run for their
money it doesn't taste bad cuz it's a
french vanilla coffee but that's way too
sweet for me we also have that latte hot
next there's the iced french vanilla
coffee which I actually might like this
more yeah this one is way better to me
it actually tastes more like coffee and
not milk next we have a caramel
cappuccino this is a vanilla cappuccino
and we have the iced caramel macchiato
let's try the caramel
cappuccino I'm not a huge fan of the
taste of this one we're missing the
Americano and the frap which I've had
before it is very sweet you will find
MAA Mac Cafe items in both the US and
Australia but the offerings are pretty
different so these are our maafe drinks
we have our long black which is
basically an Americano better and we
have our English breakfast tea our o
Gray tea we have a green tea peppermint
tea a piccolo latte a little baby Chino
I'm really jealous of those cute little
coffees that you have in Australia I
want that little tiny baby cup we have
our ice long black our Deluxe cram ble
which is IC and not here and we also
have our iced chocolate a coffee frappe
a deluxe caramel iced coffee we have
also a deluxed hazelnut iced coffee and
then last but not least our vanilla
Deluxe iced coffee I really want to try
this iced
chocolate that's not going to be good
for my stomach but this is really good
it's like a cocoa powder chocolate
flavor like it's not too rich teas at Ma
I don't know anyone that would get a tea
I mean unless you're like a British
exper I want to try peppermint tea
because did I put milk in my peppermint
tea too what why would you put milk in a
in a herbal
tea oh that's PD did you know that Ma
Cafe was actually created in Australia
in Melbourne in
1993 the first Cafe was opened in
Swanson Street I'm pretty sure we pride
ourselves in our coffee espe especially
people in Melbourne without Melbourne or
Australia you wouldn't be having mac
Cafe so thank you I will take all the
glory this is our maafe food we have a
barbecue bacon and cheese toasty which
we don't have here we have a ham and
cheese toasty we have a cheese and
tomato toasty we have a Cheesy toasty
banana bread with blueberries we really
like banana bread here and then just
your plain banana bread we usually stock
raisin toast with butter but they were
out of stock with that today we have our
double chocolate muffin an apple crumble
muffin we also have a chocolate donut
and because we like to keep it a little
bit fancy we have a chocolate macaron
and we also have a salted caramel
macaron Australians we really love our
caramel salted caramel normal caramel we
have it with
everything that's a really nice saled
caramel good job macers another thing
we're missing here in the US maafe is
the food those are all gone from the
menu and we have a theory we have a
theory that it's because they're opening
up their new cosmics restaurant which is
I guess a MC Cafe turned into a
restaurant it's going to be like Bakery
items and coffees and just that if you
want to end your Mac's meal with a sweet
treat we have some exclusive dessert
options for you starting off with a Milo
mflu there was supposed to be a mteza
but they were all out of them so so we
got the best the better option which is
Milo if you don't know what Milo is Milo
is an Australian like classic you can
put it in your drinks you can put it in
um on ice cream it's just a chocolate
powder that is so good we didn't have a
raspberry and costard Pie they were sold
out of that as well we have a strawberry
sundae a caramel sundae and then we
have a Cadbury Flake soft serve oh my
gosh the flake has been consumed by the
ice cream you can't even see the flake
anymore
RP we have our Frozen Fanta raspberry
frozen Fanta blueberry frozen Fanta
mango and our Frozen Fanta grape I
really want to try this Smo McFlurry
literally what my dreams have been made
of this is unreal this is so yum our
only exclusive dessert option is the
chocolate chip cookies which I think in
the realm of fast food cookies this is
definitely at the top because they stay
soft and they're actually pretty good a
perfectly fine chocolate chip cookie
outside of maafe drinks we have a couple
of exclusive soft drinks here in
Australia we have a Vanilla Coke we have
a Coke Zero and sparkling water while
it's technically not an exclusive it's
also worth noting that in Australia we
call our milk shakes thick shakes the
reason why we call our milkshakes thick
shakes is because a milkshake is
different in Australia so milkshake is
literally just a sweetened milk so if
you were to get a strawberry milkshake
it would just be a really thin
strawberry tasting milk with a thick
Shake it's a thicker consistency in
front of me though I have the sweet tea
the orange High SE and the two milk
options that they offer which is regular
and a chocolate milk do not be fooled by
this very naturally occurring color it
is not real fruit juice highy is
something entirely its own
thing Australians love McDonald's or
it's more commonly known here as macis
the nickname is so popular that
McDonald's has actually leaned into it
and formally embraced it it's always
called macas that being said though it
can get confusing as Maca can also refer
to anyone with a surname that starts
with MC or Mac m AC so McDonald's equals
macers but Paul McCartney for an example
is also called Maca so the context is
really crucial here McDonald's has the
second highest number of stores of any
fast food chain in Australia ranking
just below Subway that number stands to
rise too with reports saying that
McDonald's is planning to spend billion
Australian dollars opening and
renovating stores in the coming years
anecdotally
I think mackers is way more popular than
Subway just because it's convenient and
I think it everyone always craves like a
burger and I feel like the idea of
Subway isn't as appealing as McDonald's
is there are over 13,000 locations here
in the US so I think it's fair to say
that Americans love their McDonald's you
can't go like a few miles without seeing
golden arches they are absolutely
everywhere I don't know a single person
who's never tried it I don't think
America has a national dish but if we
did I'd feel like it would be a burger
fries a milkshake Andora soda like
that's so American in my brain and
that's why McDonald's in itself feels
like such an American food chain
McDonald Australia has tried to adapt
its menu to local tastes over the years
one of the examples was that of the
recent potato scallop controversy yes I
know it sounds bizarre what is a potato
scallop so many questions but in January
of 2023 mackers announced a new menu
item and it was called a potato scallop
with chicken Salt so this sparked an
online debate as the states of Victoria
and Tasmania refer to this as a potato
cake whereas other areas call it a
potato Fritter some claim that the name
is an insult to potato cakes to be
honest I don't care but so many
Australian do and it is like
institutionalized in them that they need
to care about what a potato cake is
actually called basically if you also
don't know what a potato cake is it's
literally just like a deep fried potato
with chicken salt on on top of it and
chicken Salt is also an Australian
classic it's sadly not on the menu
anymore so at least that debate can be
put on hold for now in America I would
say that McDonald's is pretty much
exactly the same everywhere I don't
think that they adapt to local tastes to
that degree but they do vary from
country to Country so for you Americans
I have some hot tea to share with you so
basically somebody said our prime
minister had his pants at ingine
MacDonald's in 1997 after a football
Grand Final it was such a popular
response like so many people kept on
like trolling him online like on Twitter
and just being like Scott Morrison did
you actually your pants and he
would ignore it but eventually he went
to an event I I think it may have been a
charity event event and he had to
address it but he left us in the Lurch
basically still saying he can't confirm
nor deny if he shot his pants at
McDonald's in 1997 we need some closure
Scott Morrison if you're listening to
this just tell us the truth the people
have a right to know this information we
can't talk about McDonald's and not
mention the McDonald's cast of
characters Grimace just had his birthday
in which we got a celebratory Grimace
shake it was okay but there's others
like Ronald McDonald which I feel like
as a kid he was such a big deal nowadays
McDonald's doesn't really push their
characters the way that they used to
after a little bit of dating we found
out that McDonald's kind of took Ronald
out of the spotlight a bit after the
2016 clown scare do you guys remember
this people were dressing up like clowns
to try to terrify people with like
weapons and stuff it was like a whole
issue people were just doing it to scare
people and they said Ronald
unfortunately we're going to have to sit
you out for the rest of your life he's
still on the cake though he's still on
the sheet cake so I think that counts
for something oh the sheet cake we
didn't get by the way McDonald's has a
sheet cake that you can ask for they did
try to phase the characters back in in
2022 with the adult Happy Meal which
featured all of the old characters but I
don't know if they're taking off as much
as they did in the '90s
a Big Mac in the US costs
13.88% more but if you go with a medium
you'll be paying around
0.6% Less in the US and a large Big Mac
meal is
2.8% less in the
US here's the nutrition of our
Australian Big Mac here's the nutrition
breakdown of a US Big Mac we have more
calories fat carb sugar and sodium but
less protein interesting Al medium fries
has 297 calories our fries have more
calories and more carbs yet less sodium
and less sugar that's actually a big
shocker that we have less sodium because
every time I've gotten McDonald's fries
they are like perfectly salty or overly
salty Al medium Coke is 136 calories our
medium Coke has more calories but also
the cup is bigger so the total meal is
is
997 calories in the US total is
1,120 calories that's a 12.3% increase
in the
US here are the ingredients of an
Australian Big Mac a key distinction
between the beef in Australia and the US
is the majority of cattle in our country
is grass-fed while in the US beef is
mostly grain fed grain fed tends to have
a bit more of a uniform taste and
texture whereas grass-fed is heavily
influenced by seasonal and Regional
factors resulting in a diverse range of
complex flavors and textures
Additionally the high concentration of
beta carotene in Grass contributes to a
more pronounced taste in the fat found
in Grass bed beef The Taste can be quite
different and Australians take pride in
M8 a US Big Mac contains all of this a
few things to note the pickle slices
contain Alum which is used to dissolve
steel and polysorb 80 which has been
linked to colon cancer this means we can
cue the dancing
mice caramel color is on California's
list of chemicals that may cause cancer
or reproductive toxicity one thing we
want to note is the quality of the US
Big Mac and McDonald's burgers in
general in November McDonald's revamped
how it cooks and prepares its Burgers
including the Big Mac they've added more
sauce up upgraded to a buttery bio bun
the cheese is more melty and the
vegetables are fresher there actually
aren't very many vegetables in this
burger but the lettuce doesn't look
wilted like it looks like fresh lettuce
these are the ingredients in our fries
which are vegan friendly
wo here's everything that's in the
McDonald's fries in the US they are not
vegan friendly because there is a beef
flavoring added in whatever they're
doing I'm sorry it's working these fries
are good and in Australia our Coke is
actually made out of real sugar whereas
the US Coke contains high proof do corn
syrup H I'm going to eat you Scot
Morrison don't to fame me I'm just
reading what people have said I'm going
to take a bite at this
table that's a lot more inviting that
looks like a a demon burger that I'm not
ready to eat right this second